You can't use a crane kick to
solve all of life's problems,
but you can come close. The ending
of "Cobra Kai" season 5 proves it.
After five seasons, it seems that Cobra
Kai's dojo war may finally be over.
Terry Silver monopolized karate classes in
the valley just in time to get sent to prison,
and his students departed in a mass
exodus after discovering that he was
both a cheater and a felon. While it's unclear
exactly what will become of his many dojos,
it seems that he won't be around to continue
teaching his abusive style to kids any time
soon. Additionally, Johnny and Daniel's rivalry
is mostly quenched by the time Season 5 starts,
and they become true friends by the finale.
So the dojo war must be over... right?
Well, that still remains to be
seen. By the end of Season 5,
there are basically no kids left to
carry on the tradition of evil karate.
Tory, Kenny, and Devon — the last three main
characters enrolled in the dojo — all repent
for their harmful ways and make amends with
the good guys by the time Episode 10 concludes.
It seems certain that Silver will serve hard time
for his crimes, and while John Kreese does escape
from prison by the end of Season 5, he's in no
position to start teaching again. Still, some
things remain murky. Will Kreese somehow reclaim
the dojos? Will Johnny? Will new evil sensei Kim
Da-Eun take the reins? The war may be over,
but there's still the aftermath to deal with.
For most of the finale, it's implied that
John Kreese might be dead after a brutal
stabbing in prison. And given the widespread
harm Kreese has wrought throughout his life,
an unceremonious end of that
nature almost seems fitting.
"Sweep the Leg."
However, the final scene of "Season 5"
shows that Kreese is still very much alive.
After besting a number of his fellow inmates
in a brawl, Kreese earns their loyalty.
This allows him to stage a fake stabbing.
When two of the other prisoners start arguing,
Kreese makes a show of getting in between
them to stop the fight, but his only reward
is what appears to be a fatal attack. After
being taken into a less secure medical area,
it's revealed that the blood on his shirt
isn't blood, but red Jell-O — a callback to
earlier in the season. The only way this plan
would have worked is if both arguing prisoners
were in on it from the start, which seems to
be the implication. Kreese then dispatches
the surrounding guards and escapes using a
keycard stolen from the prison psychologist.
With Terry Silver likely heading to jail himself,
Kreese looks primed to return as the Big Bad of
the show going forward. However, he also seems
to genuinely want a shot at redemption.
It remains to be seen if he'll get one.
The shadow of Pat Morita's Mr. Miyagi
has always loomed large over "Cobra
Kai." His absence is particularly felt in Season
5 because of Terry Silver's expanded
role as the show's ultimate villain.
Any fan of "The Karate Kid" would probably
put good money on a prime Mr. Miyagi having
the edge on any of the "Cobra Kai" characters
in a fair fight, but he's sadly not around to
stand up against Silver. Or is he? Over the
course of Season 5, Silver defeats both Daniel
LaRusso and Chozen Toguchi in one-on-one
duels. Though Chozen is still decently
inebriated when he faces Silver, and Daniel is
completely ambushed. But in the season finale,
Daniel is victorious in his rematch, thanks
to Chozen having softened him up beforehand.
In the end, it takes both Daniel and Chozen
to take Silver down, which is kind of poetic.
As the two most direct descendants
of Mr. Miyagi's karate style,
they combine to form some approximation
of what the old master was capable of.
In this way, it's almost like Mr. Miyagi
himself defeats Silver and Cobra Kai,
which makes it especially significant that Daniel
finishes the villain off with a crane kick.
From the start, "Cobra Kai" has been a show
about rivals and rivalries. Johnny re-opens
the Cobra Kai dojo because he's still not over
losing to Daniel in "The Karate Kid." Daniel,
in turn, starts training new Miyagi-Do
students because of the same rivalry.
As the show progresses, numerous other
storylines emerge in the same vein,
from Miguel and Robby's mutual hatred
to the beef between Sam and Tory.
By the end of "Cobra Kai" Season 5, pretty
much all of those rivalries have melted away.
Daniel and Johnny are friends, Miguel and
Robby make amends, Tory and Sam join forces,
and even the dojo war itself seems to end with
the arrest of Terry Silver. Even the smaller
rivalries, like the one between Robby and Kenny
Payne, are quashed by the end of the season.
With Kreese escaping from prison, there's still
a potentially villainous force on the loose,
but "Cobra Kai" might be better off exploring
a different kind of rivalry going forward.
The main storyline still left hanging at the end
of Season 5 is the international karate tournament
known as the Sekai Taikai, to which all three main
"Cobra Kai" dojos are invited. For a while, it
looked like the show's main rivalries would play
out there, but now that everyone's friends again,
the tournament could be even more interesting. A
friendly rivalry can be just as compelling as a
hateful one, and the characters now have a chance
to learn from each other and become even stronger.
There are still some plot threads left dangling in
the wind after the events of "Cobra Kai" Season 5,
but the season finale still manages to feel
like a full-circle moment for the entire
"Karate Kid" saga. The only thing missing is
an appearance from Hilary Swank's Julie Pierce,
star of "The Next Karate Kid." but when
it comes to the original trilogy starring
Mr. Miyagi and Daniel LaRusso, "Cobra Kai"
Season 5 ties up pretty much every loose end.
The events of the first film are finally and fully
laid to rest with the brotherly bond established
between Daniel and Johnny. Miyagi-Do continues on
to the next generation, and Cobra Kai is defeated.
"The Karate Kid Part II" also receives a second
pass with Season 5's extensive arc for Chozen.
And of course, Daniel finally puts Terry
Silver in his place, facing the trauma he
caused him in his youth and defeating him with
Mr. Miyagi's signature move, the crane kick.
Even the earlier plotlines of "Cobra Kai"
feel mostly wrapped up by the end of Season 5.
The original generation of teens — Robby,
Miguel, Sam, and Tory — now have their own
acolytes in Kenny and Devon, among others. In
this way, Season 5 feels like the end of a cycle,
and while there's still an international
tournament to attend, the story feels
like it's properly entering a new chapter.
Even Mike Barnes gets a bit of redemption.
"Daniel, If there is one guy in this world that
doesn't owe me an apology, believe me, it's you."
One of the smaller storylines at
the end of "Cobra Kai" Season 5
involves Chozen's secret love for Kumiko,
the woman he grew up with in Okinawa.
Chozen confesses his feelings to Johnny during
their booze-soaked night out in Episode 9,
and Johnny leaks the details to Daniel.
After receiving encouragement from them both,
Chozen calls Kumiko and confesses some
level of his feelings. But with all the
excitement that occurs directly after, this
plotline is left hanging after the finale.
It would be cute to see Chozen and Kumiko get a
happy ending together, especially given all they
went through in "The Karate Kid Part II." Chozen
was undoubtedly a terrible person in his youth,
but that's partially due to the harmful
influences he had in his life. Either way,
he's clearly repentant and makes a meaningful
redemption journey in "Cobra Kai" Season 5.
After surviving an almost fatal duel with Silver,
Chozen definitely deserves some time to rest,
and it seems likely that Kumiko
would be interested in joining him.
Many of the other big "Cobra Kai"
romance storylines come back to a
point of balance by the end of Season 5. Daniel
and Amanda's marriage is stronger than ever,
Johnny makes real strides to be a better man
for Carmen, Sam and Miguel get back together,
and so do Tory and Robby. After so much
drama, it's nice to see everyone happy.
Terry Silver gets a big promotion from
co-villain to Big Bad in "Cobra Kai" Season 5,
and he presents a very different kind of evil
than that of John Kreese. Measured and calculated
in almost every area of his life, Silver is
obsessed with dominance on a big-picture level.
His plans are global, fitting for a man
of his considerable financial resources.
But in the Season 5 finale, we also see the manic
persona Silver wears in "The Karate Kid Part III."
Thomas Ian Griffith truly stands out in Season
5, and he has a particularly great performance
in the final episode. You can see something shift
behind Silver's eyes when Johnny, Chozen, and Mike
Barnes break into his house, a flicker of the rage
and ego hidden beneath his veneer of civility.
At his core, Silver wants an excuse to
fight. It's the reason he leaves his quiet,
rich life in "Cobra Kai" Season 4 to team up
with Kreese again. All the wealth he's acquired
through nefarious means is hollow without the
ability to demonstrate his actual strength,
so he challenges Chozen to a sword fight. And even
after nearly losing, Silver seems okay with death.
"I was meant to die on the battlefield. Do it."
To win the fight, he uses a dirty tactic
to defeat Chozen. It's this duplicity in
Silver — the claims of honor with the acts of
cowardice — that ultimately leads to his downfall.
Perhaps the most shocking thing about
"Cobra Kai" Season 5 is that good
truly wins. Nearly every piece of
the story ends in a triumphant way.
Silver loses, his students abandon
the dojo, everyone makes amends,
and nobody dies. It's almost like a fairy
tale, albeit one with a lot more karate.
In the world of "Cobra Kai," though, this
isn't out of place. Throughout the show,
evil has only ever won when employing dirty
strategies. Sam loses "Cobra Kai" Season 4's
All-Valley Tournament because of
a corrupt referee, for instance.
Silver defeats Chozen with a slice from his
sword while Daniel's friend is distracted.
In this world where balance is an absolute
aspirational value, the only thing holding
most characters back is their own issues. But
in Season 5, those issues mostly get resolved.
Robby reconnects with his father, who gets his own
life fully together in turn. Sam and Tory admit
their past mistakes and move forward, as does
Chozen. And in the final moments of the season,
the Cobra Kai dojo is defeated by the revelation
that Silver is actually a duplicitous snake.
Yes, the good guys win in "Cobra Kai" Season
5, but they win by redeeming the villains, not
by dominating them. Silver is the only character
not offered some kind of redemption in the season,
and it's no coincidence that he's
also the only one left in chains.
For all the closure provided by the end of "Cobra
Kai" Season 5, there are still some things left
unresolved. The biggest hanging storyline involves
the Sekai Taikai, the massive international karate
tournament that Miyagi-Do and Eagle Fang will
compete in. That sure sounds like the kind
of event that would be a perfect send-off
for the show, but that remains to be seen.
There are still some lingering questions that
could be answered in a final tournament arc.
Julie Pierce, the only major character from the
"Karate Kid" movies yet to appear in the series,
could finally show up and share
stories about Mr. Miyagi with Daniel.
Miguel's father could return as the backer
of one of the tournament's other entrants,
given his connections to professional
fighting. And, of course, Kreese could
show up to screw everyone over, or possibly
to actually redeem himself once and for all.
What makes the international tournament plot so
interesting is the newly mended relationships
between the main characters. It would be
fun to watch Tory and Sam actually bond
over a sparring match, or see Miguel and
Robby team up in some kind of two-on-two.
"Cobra Kai" Season 5 is at its best when it lets
the characters really get to know each other
and push each other to change for the better.
With luck, we haven't seen the last of that.